you could forgive the soldiers outside
this town in eastern Ukraine for failing
to be friendly last time strangers made
an appearance they did so with a bang
the locals say the pro-russian rebels
came with a 100 tanks this Frontline
city was saved by the
ceasefire
Mar is one of Ukraine's most industrial
cities and the elich plant named after
Lenin is now owned by the country's
richest
man nearly 50,000 people toil round the
clock at just two of rat aka's plants in
mup this one plant can produce enough
steel to make a 100 aircraft carriers
but production has nearly haved here
thanks to shortages of the coal that
comes from Rebel held territory some of
the steel now makes the anti-tank
obstacles at the
checkpoints ak's appeal to his workers
not to join the rebels is credited with
keeping at least some of the East under
kev's control a $500 a month pay for a
steel worker is good money here many of
his factories on the other side have
shut
Factory workers also take part in police
patrols to maintain order they're not
equipped to stop an invading Army and
it's not just the industry that's
important here down this road you come
to Russia that way is Crimea and the
only way for Russia to connect the two
do is to take this highway and capture
the city of
marup it's
Saturday time to celebrate family and
unity it's also time for a pro Ukrainian
demonstration buto was occupied by
pro-russian rebels for a month and a
half this summer before Federal forces
took it back why have you all gathered
here we all gathered here to show
uh to marup to show to Ukraine to show
to Russia that we don't need any help
from Russia we don't need any occupants
here during our short visit one
checkpoint was shelled three Ukrainian
soldiers wounded another three suspected
separatists arrested more than anywhere
marup is keeping its eye on the truce
what happens in this Frontline Town
matters far beyond its
borders